oh yeah oh hello I'll post on discord
just to tell people that you're alive
late it's 9:00 a.m. not late night I
know we live man it's late here
hello Russian yo yo yo you're go no no
we're flashing we've been here all
weekend well know these guys I'm a
slacker I went out party today but uh
we're preparing you are your comma twos
these are the ones that flash good and
those are the ones that flash bet and
those are the ones we have in flash yet
oh yeah yeah there's a lot more well
we'll go look at the more in a minute
yeah but you know we're we're yeah no
leaks on any of this stuff so this is
this is what's provisioning all your
karma two's they show up as comatose in
the database yes all good look we have
provisioning tasks really nice where
we're at some really nice provisioning
tassets um we want to make sure that
none of these have bugs for you guys you
know oh look we're doing power
breakdowns so yeah you know
oh yeah the desert white edition is that
only can we show them that doesn't read
edition that's never gonna sell them
we're never gonna ship them desert white
uh this was the internal prototype you
know how Apple never shows you the
internal prototype no you get you get
black comet ooze yeah no this is too
disgusting desert white yeah yeah we're
gonna clean all these , tools off we're
gonna put them in some boxes for you
guys as soon as they're done and they
pass all of our tests I can't believe
I'm drinking this Buble [ __ ] you ran out
of spindrift
all right
look at this we got boxes I'm gonna put
them in these boxes
just good boxes we got foams over here
tons of foams for comma twos that's the
back seat yes oh wait oh yeah I forgot
about all these comma twos yeah we get
we get all these common tools over here
we got common powers here all the phones
oh yeah we're making a lot of comma twos
guys yeah we're getting a lot of
complicate these are these are just
boxes full of unprocessed phones yeah
this is weird they want to know where
the harnesses are oh yeah we got enough
powers to
we got we got shipping 300 comment who's
on Monday is gonna be is gonna be crazy
should should we tell them that if they
still buy one they can still if you buy
one you can still get another 300 but
just barely just barely you can still
get in but we've sold almost 300 of
these oh you might get a hoodie oh yeah
yeah yeah we're the authors those the
hoodies that we're getting away yeah
yeah check them out just not what's
inside the car just to welcome to the
fleet yeah yeah oh I get off in our
discord yeah do we ship the hoodies to
India we ship the hoodies worldwide DHL
goes will ship their weight oh we don't
ship to Russia anymore oh wow no do we
have like a we don't ship to Iran I'm
sorry it's illegal for us we'd love to
we don't want to reject our any in
business but I don't think we're allowed
to I think there's sanctions but will
absolutely ship to India , twos yo you
know what's in those boxes over there
more common powers and harnesses 3000 we
test all the phones
how long to prep a comma to write now
way too long right now it takes so long
we're practically losing money on them
no that's a lie but you know it takes
longer than I'd like we're spending more
money than I'd like they're really nice
though I hope I've been I've been I've
been talking I've been saying over and
over this week I'm like we got to make
these ones really beautiful because I
know that you guys who bought them are
gonna uh they're gonna go tell your
friends about how beautiful it is and
they're gonna buy more and that's gonna
continue the cycle should I should I
show you we'll take a quick look at it
we'll take a quick look at it for a
minute it's unreal
yo it's unreal that's this month well
not this month's a little bit more than
this month but uh yeah so a lot of these
things comes up well
we are profitable for the month of
January and you guys are gonna have fun
whoo to catch this video live you guys
are gonna have fun check it and off
checking the the replays for this
yeah test them out installed over here
you know I know you guys all can't wait
to install that dash cam saw her it's
just awful oh yeah yeah yeah we maybe
maybe this tour real fast um remember
that if you're in America we do say that
farm is us only right but if you're in
America you get three free months of
comma Prime with your device and that
means that you'll be able to install the
software without even having to connect
to Wi-Fi nice just a quick video that's
pretty much all I wanted to show five
you don't really have 34 it's late it's
late it's really late
yeah now we can have coatings James
maybe maybe we can go back to coatings
chimps but I just want to show you guys
that the comma twos are real and
hopefully hopefully assuming assuming
this all works
assuming all our provisioning works I'm
sure well assuming it all works we will
be shipping them out on Monday do you
guys
yeah
that's that quick YouTube live we're not
gonna make the hardware schematics
open-source this is how comma makes
money we appreciate all your support if
you haven't bought one yet by a comma -
it is the best product comment I has
ever made
it's the EON without all the bugs
there's been a big spike there's been a
really big spike in Opa traffic lately
we've all got Andy's YouTube video which
wish did wonders for us and then Andy
Hubble sphere was also in that video if
you guys haven't checked it out its
autopilot versus open pilot self-driving
test more competitive where it were
competitive with with the best systems
Car and Driver also did open pilot
comparison which went out in the print
magazine
yeah it's not even online yet it's in
the print magazine so if you got a car
and driver print magazine you can check
out open pilot compared to auto pilot
and super cruise definitely people we
want to be compared to um the other
piece of big news you guys read the
medium post is that open tile is not
being developed on master we've already
merged it in quite a few pull requests
it's gonna be much easier to work with
everybody on developing it to open
source 1.0 hardware that's it
does it
bye have a good night everybody enjoy
your common twos when they arrive you
haven't bought one yet shop that comedy
eye you can still just barely get in in
the first 300 um just make sure to do
that you mean well I make new hardware
for 1.00 no this is the hydrophone point
oh the comma to is gonna run open pilot
1.0 um do I plan to provide long support
for TS SP cars
yeah bat if you remove the D s here
which we don't recommend because it
disables a B what can you do with it now
well it makes a great paperweight um you
can tell people you bought one uh what's
the number at how many have we sold
almost three hundred and we'll see Ron -
I - are you guys we've made two hundred
two hundred fifty four thousand dollars
in the last 30 days we rich boys we rich
um vision is fully open the model is
fully open I actually actually I know
there was a complaint that the models
are encrypted there in DLC format which
is not encryption at all but there's
actually a tensor flow model in there
right now hey do you have the cross wall
I think we even have the cross model if
you go right now to come open pile I'm
sure we have a cross model yeah they're
in there they're just our cross files
um zelban I mean I don't know what's
more open than that you want the data to
be open
no no no no do we do parthas ation and
pruning we do quantization for the
monitoring model i'm also if you want to
buy dana even uh hit me up we sell data
where we're sketchy like that zuckerberg
you know someone was like someone i read
it was like they're gonna be sketchy
like zuckerberg and sell data yo i wish
we could be sketchy like zuckerberg that
guy's rich
no I'm kidding I wouldn't sell data if
it was for shitty people like ads but if
it was for a self-driving car people
yeah then don't we sell the data so yeah
do we do our ell models hair looks
better thank you
come on grab get the models if you just
go into open pilot models directory now
they're fully open they're cross files
enjoy let me see if I can merge oh sweet
I can merge this pull request oh I love
merging pull request is such a good
feeling isn't the day to your main
advantage no anyway we have look put it
this way this is just real talk
we have thousand daily actives how much
does it cost to hire a thousand people
to drive around remember voce they're
driving hour two hours a day so thousand
people two hours a day let's say pay
them so you pay them ten bucks an hour
so that's 20 gay a day good quantity 20k
a day is what way mo probably spends on
janitorial services yeah let's see 7.3
million for way most janitorial budget I
could almost believe that so the data is
not you know that's that's even like
paying people ten bucks an hour you can
you can ship out stuff to people
anybody can compete on data now that's
not what our advantage is our advantage
is not being delusional like a lot of
self-driving car coming how long does it
take to train the entire driving model a
long time now
we don't buy data um last 24-hour
activity yes someone's got to write that
one I'm an engineer for that
hey now we're gonna go 15 minutes on the
stream any last questions in the last 20
seconds yes a we've talked about it
again I know I know
thank you all for supporting us thank
you all for buying common tools we're
very happy to have you here with us on
this journey if you haven't bought one
yet shop.com a tie goodnight